oh my god
rip it out of my head
oh my god he's fighting it
hi i'm noah schnapp and i play will hi
i'm millie bobby brown and i play 11.
i'm joe and i play eddie i'm natalia
dyer and i play nancy wheeler i'm my
hawk and i play robin joe here i play
steve i'm priya ferguson i play erica
hey i'm sadie sink i play max i'm caleb
mclaughlin and i play lucas and claire
my name is eduardo franco and i play
orga i'm finn wolfhard and i play mike
wheeler hi my name is charlie heaton and
i play jonathan byers we're the cast we
are the cast of stranger things and
we're here with buzzfeed to play with
some puppies puppies puppies and answer
your fan questions
[Music]
[Music]
everybody grab a puppy
oh my gosh
do you like burgers you do
oh hello
[Music]
don't force them into it you have to
like
make them love you love me
[Music]
it's so sad yes
i am so sad that it's ending
i'm going to cry when it's over it is so
sweet you know yeah we were like these
puppies at the start
and now we're like
a little older now we're like dogs we
haven't processed that yet as much all i
know is that the duffers have you know
written a good ending for the show and
that's kind of what matters it's
obviously really sad but when you have
puppies to play with it doesn't really
matter
yeah oh that one's peeing in the corner
i'd say robin probably i love copper's
character development you know what it
is i love david as an actress so much
like
for me maybe destiny i like i like
business yeah
i'd like to play steve or vechna
or oh you got a little spritz over here
is that pink or is that it's whatever
was inside the toilet oh i thought
that's what they had
burger green yeah
i don't know i really like gaton
character
uh i love justin a lot i think it would
be fun to play eleven i think it would
be fun to play
joyce oh okay
it's so perfect in the square do you see
that it's like he filled in the box wait
we're gonna smell so bad
[Music]
i auditioned for
wolverine to play the little girl the
rolling wonder the the kid didn't get it
kind of try to forget them yeah
you like the things that i'm like really
upset about haven't come out yet i was
up for spider-man oh still went to here
oh i auditioned to be in matilda on
broadway which was a bold move because i
am not a dancer i tried to go out for
annie no i cannot sing
i remember mid 90s the jonah hill movie
was a big one
really really i was into that at that
time
i actually auditioned for the
goalkeepers you were in there yeah you
did we did yeah and i was wishing that
you could have gotten it oh yeah that
would have been fun
[Music]
running up that hill by kate bush
actually kate bush i mean i do love oh
my gosh kate bush running up that hill
yeah
he feels so neglected yeah i'm so sorry
i feel like i could just like throw them
like oh my god you guys have really fat
tummies talking in your sleep by
thinking the romantics message in a
bottle
i like that song this is the day by the
the it's not 80s that's 80s yeah head
over heels tears for fears the promise
by when in rome did everybody wants to
rule the world come out in the 80s okay
i'd have that one on there foreigner
foreigner
[Music]
severance succession it's insane that's
a great show sex education on netflix
rupaul's kind of have like a guilty
soft spot for like love kind of reality
shows love island just say love island
just say you want to be a kid
maybe i'll join love island for me
either love is blind or the
ultimatum on netflix i wouldn't want to
no i wouldn't want to be like a judge
like the couple who are over it all oh
yeah just being the drama of it all
euphoria cinematography the visuals i
just i just want to look beautiful
you yeah like this like it's like
like it
who doesn't you know mrs maysville looks
like it's fun mrs mazel is awesome those
are such great actors or uh chicago
medical the news um i think all you'd
have to do is commit a crime and you
could get a very nice guest role on the
news
[Music]
like some kind of like huge 80s actor i
think that would be daniel day-lewis
uh i think yeah be fun to have like dan
aykroyd or something or
dead or alive
john belushi that'd be awesome adam's
handler oh yeah honestly that would be
great
for adam's family
the hardest one to do i actually had to
do like a rotation one once where i was
just constantly going upside down which
kind of sucked i threw up after um so
that one was pretty hard i don't like
anything with a harness really oh
they're fighting this is so funny
when i was like 12 i met murdered at
peter's and that was
that was the biggest moment of my life
leonardo dicaprio i met this party and i
was pretty starstruck one time i was in
the urinal next to steve carell that was
pretty like
whoa whoa this is crazy
peeing with steve phoebe
we've met denzel washington once we and
millie like always do we like when we're
at the awards shows we just make our
rounds with us oh we met meryl streep
yeah that was cool oh and obama obama
was the best one actually yeah i mean
like jennifer aniston oh yeah we met
that was cool
[Music]
i feel like that's actually a pretty
frequent question and i never have
anything good to say i've had people ask
me to sign like body parts that's a
pretty good answer i've seen some
tattoos of you of me of lyrics from my
songs
i do remember my audition for nancy i
mean not the lines but there's like a
scene with mike and i think a scene with
jonathan i almost didn't go
um i was very stressed out that day well
caleb we kind of like knew each
other-ish beforehand
yeah each other-ish
yeah we were on broadway together when
we were younger
and then
when i auditioned it was like the
initial audition and then like
four
callbacks
there's like a chemist
and then i got the part oh man
yeah mine was bullying uh like dropping
the camera with my oh these guys are
everybody gets loved
okay
i have divorced parents you guys can get
along
you know i have so much fun on set a
favorite behind the scenes moment
it will probably definitely be like
oh my god going into going to like
crafty in between the scenes i love
crafty
[Music]
oh my god it was so exciting i
definitely never thought
that that would ever be
possible and that our paths wouldn't
come across in that way so um really it
was a very surreal moment we had a
really cool experience together and i
think we're you know we made something
that we're all really proud of
[Applause]
oh man it was great obviously working
with shawn again was amazing i don't
know where they'll be uh
together i would imagine that's where
they'll start yeah jody's amazing she's
so talented and we're just great to work
with so
yeah
i did do that it was this um
single greatest time i've ever had doing
anything ever
i mean i think he just needs to be
stronger and just stand up for himself
more fight for what's right
dressing room carrots food yeah yeah
anything to do with carrots now dogs i
would love to just have dogs i know i
know
i'm kind of in the middle of like trying
to get a feature film made and it's like
a slacker movie it's like a comedy
and uh i hope it works out
[Music]
it was a dream come true he's the goat
in the business um i learned a lot from
him we and him both have like really bad
allergies and there was a scene we were
like we're both low-key allergic to
horses
so in the scene both of us are like
sneezing in between each line just
boogers and snot and it's supposed to be
like a dramatic like you know spotter
and sun moment but we couldn't even get
our lines up because in between every
line we were just like
it was the funniest thing
[Music]
probably just like really
messed up i don't know mike's probably
working like a cool job cool job yeah
working at a at a bowling alley
uh
that's a cool job right
operating uh like a used car dealership
in indiana i always say lucas would be
like a sergeant or something he's
probably trying to
make it to the border probably and nancy
would be trying to fix the broken news
system yeah maybe she should go into
politics journalism journalism and be
like
authentic journalism should be walking
into offices yeah where she goes rogue
and she goes off the grid robin would
just be like
taking names
just hitting him
he had it it'd be cool if we could get a
segment where like the puppies you
played with where are they now well i
would like where are they now i like i
like you said um that you'd um you'd be
like conspiracy seriously yeah yeah he
tried
either that or like on the run yeah
from what i don't know man he he he
discovered something that he should not
have discovered
he would be
probably married yeah a few kids they'll
get married yeah oh my god he's biting
me
[Music]
thank you you got into u-pen yeah
it's cool oh yeah oh yeah for what what
are you doing with business
why business because i didn't want to do
like acting
you already know how to do that i don't
know i want to try something different
i'm excited i feel like i'm like buying
a dog like when you go in and you play
with them and you look for like this is
what it feels like which one would you
choose
i would pick
i think i'm going to choose i love this
one no no you can't i've already bought
him they're all agreed we're like
restaurants
we're rescues
i wish we went to france after that i
wish i could fly with you
actually if they're smaller they can you
could fit on
you know
i don't know
i'll have to talk to the wife thank you
so much
these dogs are adoptable at north shore
animal league america don't go out don't
do drugs do dogs
make sure you watch stranger things
season four on may 27th only on netflix
[Music]
you